hi there today we'll look at grocking
generalization beyond overfitting on
small algorithmic data sets by alethea
power yuri bourda harry edwards igor
babushkin and vedant misra of openai on
a high level this paper presents a
phenomenon that the researchers call
grokking where a neural network will
generalize all of a sudden
after having
after
way the point of overfitting on a data
set so you train the network it
completely over fits on a data set
training loss is comp is down training
accuracy is 100
but it doesn't generalize at all to the
validation set and then when you
continue training the network at some
point it will just snap into over uh
into generalizing
on these data sets that they're
researching to
a like a hundred percent generalization
so 100 accuracy on the validation set
and this is extremely interesting and as
you can see the paper has been presented
at a workshop at iclear 2021 which means
that it is not yet it's sort of work in
progress so
there is still a lot of
unclear things about this phenomenon
it's a as i understand it a
phenomenological paper that just
presents look here is something
interesting that we found and i think
it's pretty cool
so we'll dive into the paper we'll look
at this phenomenon they do dig into it a
little bit
into what's happening here and try to
come up with some explanation
so the basic premise of grocking is the
graph you see on the left right here now
it is a little bit pixelish but i hope
you can still see what's happening the
red part is
the training accuracy and on the x-axis
you have number of optimization steps
and this is a log scale so that's
important to see this is a log scale for
training steps in this direction
now the training accuracy naturally
after a few steps it shoots up to a
hundred percent we're we'll get to what
data sets these things are in a second
but it's important to see the network
can in fact fit the training data
extremely well and it in it just
overfits however the validation accuracy
it if you can see it there is a little
bump here but then it goes it goes down
again almost um
i don't know whether we should even
regard this as a little bump that's
actually happening however it it just
stays it stays down it stays down and
then after you can see orders of
magnitude more steps this is 10 to the
second 10 to the third 10 to the fourth
10 to the fifth steps
it shoots up
and it starts to generalize as well
this is very interesting because um you
know
this essentially means you you keep on
training uh for a long time and when all
hope is lost still the network at some
point will will generalize now why is
this happening
and
as i understand it it's not the case
often that the network like drops down
again out of generalization though i
haven't haven't actually seen this
investigated like if they run for 10 to
the i don't know how many steps but it
seems like
once the network is generalizing is uh
has training accuracy of 100 it doesn't
fall out of that again so the question
is how does this happen like what's
happening here why is this happening why
is it all of a sudden and what makes it
work and for that it's a bit
important to understand a very related
phenomenon in fact a connected probably
phenomenon called the double descent
phenomenon in deep learning the double
descent phenomenon graph looks somewhat
similar in that the premise is that
on the x-axis you have the number of
parameters
in a network so the number of parameters
in a neural network and then on the on
the y-axis you have let's say
loss
okay or actually let's say let's say
accuracy or i'm not sure
lost most of these plots for the double
descent phenomenon are actually loss so
if you consider the training loss um
as you increase the number of parameters
in your neural network you will fit the
data better and better the training data
so you get a curve that goes something
like this and then it just stays at zero
right so there's zero training loss
um as you increase the number of
parameters
these every point on this line is a
neural network with a given number of
parameters that has just been optimized
to convergence okay that's important to
remember on the left here we saw a graph
during optimization on the right here is
a graph of many different networks all
of which have been trained to
convergence now what you see with
the validation loss in this case so if
you look at the validation loss it might
at some point it might come down with
the training loss right and then in the
classic fashion of machine learning you
as the number of parameters go up you
start to sort of overfit the validation
loss goes up again
uh because you start overfitting you
start memorizing the training data set
and then at the point where pretty much
the number of parameters equal the
number of training data points like the
number of
let's just call this n
then you have again like a really crappy
validation loss because you're just
remembering the training data however if
you increase your parameters beyond that
point so if you scale up your neural
networks even more the validation loss
will come down again and actually end up
at a lower point than
if you were on this place over here if
you had not enough parameters so there
is a point beyond overfitting
where you have more parameters than data
points and interest interestingly for
neural networks it is the case that
it happens that they
can achieve generalization in fact
better generalization with over
parameterization than comparable
underparameterized models which flies in
the face of of all statistics and
whatnot but we know this phenomenon
exists okay
so uh we we knew that um
things like this can happen like
the training loss can be perfect and
still we can have generalization right
the grocking phenomenon is a phenomenon
where
i'm i'm gonna guess i'm gonna guess the
the the creators of the double descent
phenomenon haven't looked quite as far
in order to i guess they simply ran
training to convergence for a number of
steps and then they
they they looked at the validation loss
and so i guess they would have stopped
somewhere in between here between 10 to
the third and 10 to the fourth steps
this research here is simply what
happens if we like let it run for a
really long time
then this shoots up
as well and it seems like it seems like
for a lot of conditions you you can you
can do this
so
now it's worth looking at what kind of
data sets we are we are
interested in here the data sets are
synthetic data sets in this paper the
synthetic data sets are binary operation
tables so here the data sets we consider
are binary operation tables of the form
a
and then here this is like some sort of
a binary operation a
let's just call it multiplied a
multiplied by b equals c
where a b and c are discrete symbols
with no internal structure
and the circle is a binary operation
examples of binary operations include
addition composition of permutations
bivariate polynomials and many many more
in fact they have some examples i think
down here so here you see some examples
like addition and multiplication but
also more complicated things like a
polynomial that you then um
that you then
do modulo a prime number a division
modulo a prime number and so on so
the way you'd the way you create a data
set is you construct a table
and in the table you have a number of
these symbols
and then you define binary operations by
simply filling in that table okay so if
this were i don't know like a plus a
plus b and a and b are are numbers then
right a plus b is c if a is one bs2 cs3
and so on um but you can define this as
many different things a lot of the
experiments in this paper are of the
group s5 which is the group of all
permutations of five elements which i
think has like so this is a
group with 120 elements so your table
would here be 120 by 120 and the
operation would be the sort of um
composition of permutation so every
permutation of five elements composed
with another permutation gives you yet
another permutation of five elements so
you can just construct this this table
and then what you do is you just simply
cross out
a few things in the table so you say
okay here i'm just going to cross out a
few things and this is what the network
should predict right i'm going to train
the network on the data that i have and
i'm going to predict the cells that i
crossed out
this way you can exactly measure how
good the network is right there is no
noise effectively in the data um it's
all very well defined and
a human goes about this with i guess
with sort of a logical mind they try to
figure out like ah what's the rule
what's the rule a neural network can
simply remember the training data but
then it will not generalize to the
hidden fields because it cannot memorize
those so
if a neural network generalizes here it
also
kind of means that it must have somehow
learned the rule and
this this is pretty interesting
so there are a number of quantities to
keep in mind um
the the three quantities are first of
all what's the operation uh because
there are more and less complicated
things for these networks to learn just
from the kind of difficulty the
complexity of the operation itself
second of all is the data set size or
the size of the binary table itself in
this case it's 120 by
120. 20.
and the third one is how many things are
left away so how large is the training
data fraction the fraction of the table
that is filled in for the network to
learn all of these three things are
going to play a crucial role in this in
this grocking phenomenon and when and
how it appears for example here
you see
they they have
trained
neural networks
on
this s5 group right the permutations of
groups of five elements
until they reach generalization so
they simply run it and they measure how
long does it take a network to reach 99
validation accuracy or higher right
that's that's the thing on the left is
essentially um
you know the answer would be something
like
between 10 to the 5 and 10 to the six
right
okay so and they measure this as a
function of you might not be able to
read this but it says training data
fraction okay how much of the training
data is filled in and you can pretty
clearly see if i just give it like here
20 of training data there are even some
runs that do not generalize in this
number of steps
now
would they generalize if you were to
optimize for even longer
who knows honestly
but you can see that as soon as you give
like 30 of the training data the runs in
general do generalize but they take
something like um
here yeah 10 to the 5 number of steps to
do so and then as you increase the
training date to fraction
this snap to the generalization happens
faster and faster you can see right here
as you give more training data
it goes faster and faster until it
generalizes
and the generalization happens as i
understand it yeah fairly like quickly
like it it doesn't generalize because it
remembers the training data and this
always happens as i understand it in a
fairly similar number of steps
but then at some later point it just
kind of snaps and completely generalizes
to the
validation set
and this is this is really interesting
so we know that the more training data
we have around the better right that's
one recognition
um
then the other the other thing is
they try to figure out okay um which
parts of the optimization algorithm are
are
making this grocking phenomenon happen
and here they figure out that uh
weight decay in fact is one of the is
one of the big drivers of this so if
they add weight decay to the algorithm
and they try a lot of different things
they try full batch versus mini batch
with dropout without dropout
modulating the learning rate and so on
but weight decay seems to be one of the
biggest contributors to this grocking
phenomenon to the fact or
to how fast these networks generalize
you can see that the network generalizes
much sooner if you have weight decay
turned
up
than not
also they make the observation that uh
if you have symmetric operations uh if
your binary operation is symmetric then
also the groking phenomenon happens much
faster than if you have like
non-symmetric operations this might just
be a function of these networks which if
you if you have like something like a
transformer uh you know it it's it's
sort of kind of invariant to to the
symmetry so it might like essentially
one data point is sort of
two data points in disguise if it's
symmetric or there's only half as much
stuff to learn
uh you choose whatever you you want to
interpret this as but
i think yeah this is not as important as
the weight decay and why do i highlight
this um
i highlight this because oh so down here
you can see they analyze
then
um they analyze the results of a network
that has learned to generalize
uh like this
so on the right you see a t-sne
projection of the output layer weights
from a network trained on modular
addition so this is x plus y modulo
eight i think the lines show the result
of adding eight to each element the
colors show the residue of each element
modulo eight so if you do the t snip
projection you can see the lines are
obviously drawn by the authors but you
can see there are structures where if
you go along the line right here they've
colored
essentially this is always adding eight
adding eight
so there are structures
where
um this
the rule for generating the data is
clearly present in the data itself oh
sorry in the in the network's weights
this gives you a strong indication that
the network has not only just remembered
the data somehow but has in fact
discovered the rule behind the data
and
we have never incentivized the networks
to learn these rules that's the wild
point there are
there are architectures where you try to
specifically make tell the network look
there there is a rule behind this i want
you to figure out the rule you can maybe
do symbolic regression or
i don't know like like you can try to
build an internal graph of and reason
over it no no we just train neural
networks right here and it turns out
that these networks can learn these
rules
so why do i relate this to the double
descent phenomenon in the double descent
phenomenon um it is
assumed or i've heard the authors of
these papers uh speak about their their
kind of
hypothesis why this happens and this is
a bit mixed with my my hypothesis as
well uh they speak of for example weight
decay being one possible explanation so
they say if i have a bunch of of data
points let's say i have a bunch of data
points right here
right
and i want to
do regression on them well if i just do
linear regression i have one line right
it's fairly robust right it's fairly
flat it's fairly robust because it's
just one parameter
now if i start to add parameters right i
get
maybe i get to a point where i have a
good number of parameters you know this
this polynomial maybe kind of like this
still fairly robust right you can see
how it might generalize to to new data
then right so this the blue one would be
somewhere here
the
dark blue one would be somewhere here
where the the validation loss actually
goes down with the training loss but
then when i add when i keep adding data
points uh sorry parameters then you know
classically i'll start you know my my
overfitting right here and this it will
not generalize to any point that might
be in between like one here or so
there will just go up so the green would
correspond to the point where i just
start to interpolate the training data
but then what happens if i go on if i
make even higher order polynomials or
higher order neural networks well at
that point at least these authors argue
do i have another color
this one they argue that
you get like a polynomial that or or a
curve that yes it has a lot of
parameters but it uses these parameters
such that it can be sort of smoothly
interpolate the training data now this
curve is quite complicated in terms of
the number of numbers you need to
describe it but
it uses
the fact that it has a lot of freedom
you know it can choose to be however it
wants as long as it interpolates the
training data right yet it chooses to be
smooth because of a combination of sgd
training it and of weight decay so the
weight decay would prevent any of these
numbers from getting too big and
therefore getting like super out of
whack curve
so the weight decay would in fact
smoothen the curve and that makes the
model generalize really well because the
smoothness now is reasonably generalizes
two training data points that are in
between like this data point is still
fairly well represented by the purple
curve in fact it's better than the the
dark blue curve in this particular case
so you can see that
the authors here argue that weight decay
might be an important contributor to why
over-parameterized networks generalize
and it's interesting that the these
groking
the authors of the groking phenomenon
paper here find the same thing they say
okay if we use weight decay the groking
appears to happen much faster
is this i don't know what exactly they
call grocking i'm just going to call
grocking this whenever the validation
loss
snaps all of a sudden from 0 to 100 on
these these data sets now again these
are algorithmic data sets so you know we
don't know what happens i think they
they do make experiments when they they
noise some of the data so um they they
have some noise in there and i think
they find that if they add noise then
uh it's way more difficult i'm
i'm not sure though maybe i'm confusing
papers here um
but what what might be happening right
here right
this is
it's interesting because um
what might be happening is that by
imposing this smoothness um
and the over parameterization we're sort
of biasing these networks to find like
simple solutions right
so if
if i have just very few training data
points if most of the cells here are
blacked out right the simplest solution
is simply to remember the training data
however as i get more and more training
data points
that give me more and more information
about a potential underlying rule it
becomes simpler for me to simply to
understand the underlying rule than to
remember the training data it's more
it's more difficult to remember the
training data than simply to learn
the rule so what might be happening here
is that as i train and this is always
training here the training happens
always on the same data right you simply
uh
sample the same things over and over
again train on it i think what might be
happening is that you kind of jump
around in your optimization procedure
you can see there there's some bumps in
the training accuracy here to kind of
jump around jump around
that's a song no um
so you jump around a bit and
and in your in your lost landscape there
there might be many of these
local minima where you
in fact uh
remember the training data perfectly so
you kind of jump around a bit between
them right you remember the training
data perfectly and then one of them
is just you remember the training data
as well
now this is you remember the training
data as well however the solution is
just so much simpler
that you stay there this is not a good
way of visualizing it so it must be
something like
here are the minima
where
here are the minima where
this is the training just the loss on
the data
however there is another loss and that's
the loss on like the for example the
weight decay loss and the weight decay
loss is you know it's pretty good all of
these things but then for one of them
it's just like
because that solution is so much simpler
so you're going to choose you want to
jump around between those minima jump
around
until you know once you reach this one
this loss right here that comes on top
of this is just so much lower that
you're gonna you're gonna stay there
it's like wow i found
such an easy solution
um
i'm not gonna go out again
so
yeah
now the big question is of course
how and why
does
something like sgd plus weight decay
plus potential other drivers of
smoothness in these models
how and why do they correspond to
simplicity of solutions right because
simplicity of solutions is something
that kind of we humans have built in
like okay what's the rule behind this
what's the rule is this essentially
assuming that there is a simple rule
trying to find it because it would make
our life much easier it's a simple
explanation for what's happening
the interesting part is that weight
decay or something similar something
that's happening in these neural
networks
is essentially doing the same thing even
though we don't tell it to do it so
understanding this i think is going to
be
uh quite an important um quite an
important task for the near future and
also
maybe
maybe we're not exactly right with the
weight decay maybe there is some other
constraint that we can impose that
encourages simple solutions in in the
way we care about simplicity even more
and you know once we have that um
the
it's it's like
you know there this age-old argument do
these things actually understand
anything well in this case i'm sorry but
if you have found this solution with the
rule uh essentially built into the
networks of the
into the weights of the neural network
you can say well
the network has in fact learned the rule
behind this binary operations so
you know who are we to say these
networks don't understand anything at
that point and also it gives us the
opportunity to you know train these
networks and then from the structures of
their latent spaces we might in fact
parse out the rules of data we don't
know yet so we let the networks fit and
we parse
we parse the underlying maybe physical
laws maybe
social social phenomena we parse them
out from the underlying uh data oh yeah
here okay there is an appendix where
they they list binary operations they
have tried out
models uh optimization so yeah they use
a transformer with two layers four
attention heads
um so it's not it's not a big thing and
also the data sets aren't
aren't super complicated
but it's pretty cool to see
this phenomenon now again on if if we
have real world data bigger networks
noisy data um
it's not going to
it's not going to happen as drastically
and also they say
as you increase the size of the data set
whereas that
then
this phenomenon is harder and harder so
if the entire data set is bigger uh the
the grogging phenomenon i guess it's
it's more tough to see
and also here is the experiment i
mentioned where you have several
outliers so noisy data points and as
you um so this is the fraction of
correctly labeled data points so
as you
increase the number of correctly labeled
data points you can see the grocking
happens in
more often or to a better validation
accuracy than not
so
well you can i don't know if you can
read this but
um
yeah the these these down here they have
too many outliers so with too many
outliers either the validation accuracy
just stays at zero or it just turns up
like quite late
okay that's it here is an example of one
of these binary operation tables that is
a little bit larger i don't know if it's
one of the 120
sized ones
but this is something that would be
presented to the network and they say
they say what we invite the reader to
guess which operation is represented
here
well have fun dear dear reader
um yeah
all right so this was it from me for the
rocking paper as i said this seems like
it's work in progress i think it's
pretty cool work in progress it uh
raises a lot of questions and um
i think yeah i think it's it's pretty
cool i wonder how this happened like
like how
how did how did
people find this they just forget to
turn off their computer and in the
morning they came back and they're like
whoopsie-doopsie generalized though if
you if you know if you build these kinds
of data sets i guess you have something
in mind already
yeah in any case that was it for me tell
me what what you think is going on in
neural networks or is there like is
there like a super easy occam's razor
explanation that i'm missing
i don't know tell me what you think i'll
see you next time bye